we will overcome that barrier so we
would want to
answer the questions that the users are
not asking
or they don't even know how to ask the
questions
[Music]
thank you so much for being on my show
how are you i'm good michael
thanks for calling yeah thank you very
much for being here
it's a it's a privilege to have you here
a serial entrepreneur
and you know i think that you are the
definition of a sore entrepreneur
with three successful companies behind
you already all of them were acquired
and some of them by companies that i
that i value very much i think that i
ice until
until today i still use splunk on a on a
pretty
on a pretty regular basis and now you're
on to your fourth startup and i'm very
proud to be a part of the journey
as a part of j ventures one of the
investors in the in the company
and so before we get to talk about what
this latest company is about
ramesh i'd love for you to take me back
a little bit and and
what is it about entrepreneurship and
about building companies
that really gets you so excited because
now you're on to your fourth one
so instead of calling it as an
entrepreneurship
i um let me just say that it was more
about
being passionate and being about trying
to change the world
in like a smaller way and when i
was even before i was starting my first
company
i i thought there is actually a big
product market gap
in terms of what was happening with the
evolution of the
amazon web services were just started it
was probably less than 50 people
when i first interacted with them and i
thought there is a big opportunity in
terms of
um say what the cloud could do for the
world and
how people can even get on to the cloud
and
coming from an experience and operating
systems i started my journey in
operating systems the first product i
tried to
add and build was the svr4 unix
operating system
i i spent about six years on unix
operating system trying to add features
make changes and then uh uh new
new configuration things like clustering
for ways so
i come from the space um worked on os
for about
12 years or so across companies like sun
microsystem storage deck etc
and i thought there is an opportunity to
migrate
um enterprise applications from on-prem
to cloud and also
manage these applications when i first
started
selling the product to the customers not
many customers even knew about aws so it
was actually very hard
for them to be convinced to even take a
meeting
not just as we used to partner with aws
so even for aws sales reps
and then we eventually succeeded we i i
grew the business to
about 40 million dollars yearly run rate
and
um cloud management platforms was the
one that i created but it was
less about being an entrepreneur trying
to do something
but but the idea was about being
passionate about the technical problem
and trying to
solve it so when you talk about you know
changing the world
and and your in your capacity throughout
these companies
you it sounds to me also that while
you're while talking about that you're
all you're also excited about the
technologies that you're building right
these are things that you're personally
curious about and personally passionate
about
yeah yeah so so all of these companies
are very technologically centric
companies uh
think of it as an ip centric companies
in a very positive way not in a negative
way
and i'm very passionate about using the
technology to make a meaningful change
for somebody and even in the second
company i thought um
we could use nlp in a completely
different way to
create a conversation and 2014 was when
we applied for the trademark on
conversational analytics
and then that was the company that i had
created and then we we were able to
create a meaningful impact
on enterprise customers of course we got
an acquisition offer much early in the
cycle
which we could not refuse so we got
acquired by splunk
but um their conversational analytics
meaning it was less about nfp we did not
use any
open source energy packages no stand for
nlp no
uh no other nap so we had we built it
grounds app
most of the code was actually done in
assembly so
times we we were probably only one of
the four pi companies in the whole of
bay area
who were working on smg so we wanted to
give that
experience speed and performance on the
nfp
now i don't think it could actually do
that but um
yeah it is about being passionate to
that level
that that's just that's just incredible
so passionate to level
one of four or five companies working in
assembly out of the bay area in 2014
and that's that's just incredible so
give me you know a spectrum of
of technologies that today in 2020
you're you're personally excited about
i'm
i'm very excited about nlp and i and i
focus a lot of my time at stanford on
artificial intelligence and the
different applications that it's going
to
and but but i'd love to pick your brain
on the different things that you're
particularly excited about
as we enter a new decade now um
and as any entrepreneur has to do i'm
very focused so
it is not about ai in general but
application of ai to solve a very
specific problem
in the current company in market we use
ai as an architecture
to give a play button for the enterprise
data
and also to solve a big problem in the
bi end-to-end
i'll explain what do i mean by um a play
button for the enterprise data
so think of it as we are bringing two or
three different things in ai together
to provide this benefit number one is
the google like
natural search experience and it is a
lot more than
nlp and it is about
bringing in a natural search experience
coupled with ambiguity corrections
coupled with contextual search
recommendations etc
it means that when a customer is
searching for sales in alabama we have
to figure out whether alabama is a
county or a city or a state etc so all
that is done by us
and second we understand not only the
query we answer that instantly
but we also get the raw data and apply a
series of machine learning models
and even though there are a lot of
platforms where somebody can drag and
drop the models and analyze
but it doesn't happen for every
enterprise user so think of it as a
coffee store manager of a large uh chain
that store manager cannot deal with all
these models so we
do this ml workflow ml operations on the
fly at that point in time
typical turnaround time about 300
milliseconds
wow and and we actually choose the
machine learning models we do the
feature parameter identification but
some of this can happen in an offline
basis too
and then finally we use energy to
produce english
and then narrate it as an audio visual
so
i assume that a business user is on the
go and he asks a question
how many chairs do i order um say for an
upcoming season so think of it as a
retail customer and
simply gets an audio visual on the
mobile phone and that
starts talking saying that these are the
number of chairs that you need to order
but along with the chairs you need to
buy
tables also because 38 of the customers
buy tables along with the chairs so this
is something that you need to look at so
so that intelligence we try to bring up
and then present it at that point in
time so that is what we are doing at
uh and we have built the product with ai
as an architecture rather than
as a feature so one of the things that
i'm always curious about is focus and
one of the things that you mentioned
um when i met when i talked about how i
enjoy you know
exploring the artificial intelligence
field at stanford
you mentioned that as an entrepreneur
you enjoy
and as a ceo you enjoy taking ai into an
application level
and solving a real problem and not just
with the
not just with the artificial
intelligence slogan but actually one of
the applications of it so i'm curious
within a software like like mackay and
within a company
that seems to be doing a lot right
you're solving a lot of different
problems in one
how do you maintain focus on which are
the really crucial problems to solve
especially as you're just starting out
and you're just exploring what your
users are doing
yeah so how do we identify the problem
is
um number one first trying to identify
what is the business scenario
so the business scenario or the context
is business intelligence
and business intelligence you define the
persona and then you identify what they
are and then try to do that say for
example in this particular business
intelligence as a market category
there is no use of an image recognition
just as an
example and hence we don't do anything
related to image recognition or image
identification even though it is ai
but it is more of understanding of data
understanding or uncovering the
intelligence that is in the data
automatically to the user so that is a
big business goal
and the long-term vision of us is to be
a personal business companion
of any uh enterprise data as long as the
technology can fit into the scope and
the use case
we try to stay very focused on that so
if you're looking you know 10 years in
the future about where
how businesses are utilizing data to
you know leverage both their day-to-day
activities but also their forecasts and
and their and and as they scale where
are we today
and where do you think the world will be
in 10 15 years or so
in terms of where the world is as of now
or as of yesterday without makai is that
a user has to uh or the entire data
industry is in this paradigm of what you
ask is what you get
so i assume that the business user wants
to know something
say for example somebody is asking a
question is how much was the california
wildfires this year
okay it is actually very hard to get an
answer but you see uh can get an answer
but
we have finalists looking at various
information writing a sequel etc
but nothing more than what the user is
asking and
i envision that pretty soon say us or
maybe other companies that are going to
come up in the similar space
we will overcome that barrier so we
would want to answer the questions that
the users are not asking
or they don't even know how to ask the
questions say for example
um in this scenario of the california
wildfires we may tell that
the wildfires in 2020 has been little
over 15 times
of the last year or 2020 wildfires
were greater than the sum total of the
last four or five years
so so that is an intelligence that the
user doesn't know and then
we we could tell that and eventually um
what we are working on already is to be
able to produce this intelligence
without any questions at all so i assume
that we will become a click less
and and also search less product so i
assume that if i know the business
metrics and the kpis that the users are
interested in
we would want to produce intelligence
even without them asking any questions
and we do that to some extent already
and that is how i think enterprise
intelligence will move it
so what have you learned over the past
three companies that you've built
about the life cycle of a company so
as either as an entrepreneur or as a
leader or
or business-wise what are some really
key insights that you've generated for
yourself as you're now approaching or
you're in the midst of your fourth
venture
as an entrepreneur and as a founder of
the companies one very important thing
to figure out
is is there an existing market that we
are going after or are we creating a new
market
new product category say in our case it
is business intelligence as a
market and and there are budgets and the
customers have budget cycles and then
it means that there is also a
competition there is a legacy
competition or an incumbent vendor and
it is very important to identify the
difference between
these two existing or new because the
market positioning
customers budgets everything depends on
them if you're trying to create a new
product
completely new category it's a longer
sales cycle and customers don't have
budgets they can only budget for a poc
this year
and then budget for them for the
complete implementation in the next year
or two years so
so that is actually the first one that
we need to decide
and the second thing is what is the
value add for a customer
right you can build great but if it
doesn't deliver a customer value
again customers may not perceive a value
in there
and third is that can your product stand
up on its own
or does it need an ecosystem of other
things
that need to push the adoption
so if somebody can understand these
three things
it's it's easier to say were there any
challenges that kept presenting
themselves that
almost seemed to get easier and easier
with every venture but
they were the same in nature so the same
challenge but you were able to tackle it
with more and more experience
it is not always this same challenge
because if in case you see a challenge
most of the times in the next venture
you are better prepared and you don't
see the same challenge it is probably a
different challenge that you will
encounter and in this
company if i had to tell what is the
technological challenge that we had
to overcome was the asynchronousity of
this machine learning models these makes
some of these models can take a long
time to execute
and if i have to take the input from the
search and then
instantly produce the video 300
milliseconds some models may not respond
in that time
so we had to build the audio or a video
engine that works in a synchronicity in
nature
so it means that as the video starts
playing we might start appending content
to it
so the progress bar can go backwards
and not just forwards because the total
time increased
but um but we try to make sure that that
experience is
seamless and also uh present the user
experience now
very easy matter so yeah what what are
some other
interesting problems that you're excited
about so
obviously a lot of it is is in the world
of what maca is doing now but
what what are some other you know big
picture problems that you think are
worth tackling
if for example young entrepreneurs from
stanford already 200 are listening to
this
um i think there is a big opportunity in
the educational space
um coming from having built a company in
educational space and
in my select year or the third company i
see that there is a lot more bigger
opportunity
the existing platforms and solutions are
a bit monotonous
and they don't personalize the content
they don't personalize the delivery
there is a lot of opportunity and as an
entrepreneur somebody would also may uh
have a guarantee that people would pay
for this uh
pay for the products that they consume
so
education in my opinion is on the top of
the funnel
and after that i think insurance and
healthcare i think
could go through a lot of uh change uh
assuming that the
governments don't stop um some things
coming into the ai
space 100 i mean obviously with
healthcare we've seen a dramatic
acceleration of change and adapt and
adoption
in 2020 and i myself am also a part of a
hippo insurance and insure tech company
based in the bay area so i can see
firsthand that the revolution that
insurance is going through
in in these past few years and it's just
remarkable ramesh
thank you again for both for coming on
on the show and sharing your insights
but also for allowing
and myself aj ventures to be a part of
your hopefully your your new success
story
uh and it's still it's remarkable i
think
for me for me to think of sitting in
front of somebody who's done
it three times already successfully
going on the fourth one
but at the end it's not about the money
and it's not about the fame it's about
being passionate about the technology
and passionate about about improving the
lives of either people or companies or
or
or people that are that are working
their day-to-day to ask the most
meaningful questions
and i think that it's i think that it's
really remarkable before we leave
i have to ask you the most important
question which is three words that you
would use to describe yourself
and why those three words um
so so the three words
just thinking on the fly so number one
is that i'm very passionate
about trying to a problem whether it is
working say 12 hours 14 hours a day um
and the second thing is i'm very
compassionate to the team and then i try
to
think from their perspective to
understand them and then make sure that
i help them i encourage them to to get
things done
and the third is fun part of it making
sure that it's a fun experience every
day
i love it i love it ramesh thank you so
so much this is so great best of luck
with the company
and and i look forward to keep it
working with you over these next few
years
okay and then thank you for asking all
the good set of questions and i
appreciate
all the involvement and then trying to
do this and and
good luck with your ventures thank you
very much take care okay thank you
you